no
y las lágrimas de alegría son del hijo
de sophie petrona luego de que ella se
bajó del avión en bamako su hijo que
jugó un papel fundamental en su
liberación solo lamentó que no hubiese
ocurrido antes hice lo mejor que pude
pero existe lo que pudiste hiciste lo
que necesitabas pero no fue suficiente
[Música]
no te dije nadie es perfecto en este
mundo
de todas por su parte dijo que nunca
perdió la esperanza
en el fondo siempre estaba asegura que
volvería que no moriría mientras tanto y
me dije a mí misma no le des tanta
importancia a la muerte porque no sabes
dónde cuándo cómo pasar a buscar
chinchipe
como el amigo más algo entonces me dije
no importa sigue adelante
mantente fuertes espera era el dicho de
mi hijo fue lo que dijo en un vídeo
espera espera y eso fue lo que hice la
mujer de 75 años quien dirigía una
organización para huérfanos fue
secuestrada por los yihadistas en mali
en 2016 liberada junto a otros tres
retenidos persona fue la última francesa
secuestrada en todo el mundo ella le
dijo a los periodistas en bamako que
planeaba ir a francia oa suiza en un
tiempo cercano pero eventualmente espera
regresar a malí para continuar con su
trabajo de caridad